camaro lori lightfoot attacking kaylee
mcinerney
accusing the white house press secretary
of being a karen
after she called the mayor derelict over
the surge of violence
in that city here's mcinerney responding
on
waters world that airs this weekend i'm
very upset about the violence in the
streets of her city you know she's
focused on words
but instead she should be focused on
actions i understand the truth hurts
the president's written her a letter and
offered her help and she needs to take
it and cnn's jim acosta getting slammed
for taking the press secretary out of
context acosta claimed mac and any said
that
the science should not stand in the way
of reopening schools
but here's what really happened the
science should not stand
in the way of this and as dr scott atlas
said i thought this was a good quote of
course we can do it everyone else in the
western world our peer nations are doing
it
we are the outlier here the science is
on our side here and we encourage
for localities and states to just simply
follow the science
open our schools jessie tell me a little
bit more about that
interview with kaylee what else did she
say she mentioned that jim acosta is the
kind of guy that's a real
jerk when the cameras go on and then
afterwards he's the nicest guy in the
world
um it's like the opposite of me i'm like
so nice on tv but then i'm a jerk
in real life i just keep
vouch um honestly i think the mayor of
chicago needs to start
karen a little bit more about her people
dying
because that's the point here it's funny
how a lot of these liberal mayors were
begging the president for all this
federal aid during
the pandemic but then when black on
black crime was surging
and people's stores were being robbed
and fires were
burning they didn't want any of the
president's help all of a sudden i think
the memo went out
to democratic mayors that we have to
refuse the president's help because the
president is getting good press when
that happens so they'd rather stop the
president from getting good press
than stopping their own people being
killed it is weird though
that she says well if he really wanted
to help
he would you know make sure people that
were on no-fly lists couldn't buy guns
or
do more background checks or ban assault
rifles does the mayor of chicago really
think the people squeezing the triggers
are on no-fly lists or they're buying
their guns legally
or that are really using ar-15s instead
of handguns
the fact that we buy this line from her
without
challenging her makes you realize how
corrupt this whole media deal
is well juan it's also i mean it's
really kind of worthless to just engage
in this partisan bickering
and it's really easy for the mayor's the
president just needs to shut his face
because that's a kate brown said too
in oregon but wouldn't it be a little
bit better if if some of these mayors
actually came up of a list of things
that they were doing
and that they were going to to put in
place in the near future to make their
cities safer to make people citizens
there feel better wouldn't you rather
hear that from lori lightfoot
look i think kennedy she's a local
official she was elected by the people
of chicago she answers to the people of
chicago
and i would imagine they have demands
and pressures on her the council members
and all the rest
state officials as well in trying to
protect their citizens
i just don't see it as a federal
responsibility that's not the way our
country
is structured we don't run in and tell
local officials
how to run their schools how to run
their police department unless you want
to make it a political issue
and with regard to kaylee mcinanny
listen i think that if you're the chief
communications officer
for the president of the united states
you need to be clear
and precise in your language everyone
knows the president wants schools to
reopen this fall
so she can't start making the case by
saying science should not start
stand in the way before she gets to
citing a scientist and citing documents
because guess what people are going to
say wait you said science shouldn't
stand
in the way and then she says you took me
out of context no i
think she was not clear she was not
precise even jimmy carter
people are co-worker jake tapper said
that
he unfairly took her out of context and
and by the time
correct by the time he tweeted out a
correction
he had already gotten 30 000 likes on
that tweet so
that part of it is dishonest and and
there are there are teachers
no there are academics there are
scientists there are doctors
uh there are parents there are kids who
want schools to open
so she's not alone in that and that is
not simply a political issue
as far as the cities yes the cities need
to be run by the officials unfortunately
a lot of these cities we're talking
about
are being run into the ground uh greg
let's talk about the most important
local officials well officials are doing
a bad job
okay they should be thrown out of office
if if they're doing a bad job great
that's like the local voters okay okay
um
it's interesting that when their bodies
piling up
juan says that's a local issue but when
it's a police incident
it becomes a national story that
involves every single media outlet that
causes protests
and then later riots and looting it's a
national it's a global issue that
affects england but when their bodies
piling up in chicago
ah it's a local issue mind your own
business
look we saw with the costa rica we saw
with acosta that trump is right
that fake news is the enemy of the
people one of those powerful statements
since tear down this wall
and it's really good that we see this in
action because every day the public gets
more and more red pilled
that it's the media that is manipulating
the news
in order to create dissent so that they
can get more clicks
and they don't just do this by the way
to public figures like kaylee
if you've ever been the subject of a a
story
you know you weren't treated fairly
because there's always an inclination
for a reporter
to create a sensation out of nothing
you know a beach a beach without a shark
attack is just a beach
so you need that shark attack but i've
got to tell you finally it is a joy to
watch
kaylee because it provides a contrast
what you have on one side in the in the
press core
are these whiny petty dudes right
compared to this stoic terminator
shooting lasers made of facts into their
dissonant brains
is a positive joy for me makes my day
every day
and and you can make your night tomorrow
night by watching not only the great
gutfeld show but also
yes watersworld and you can see that
exclusive interview with kaylee mcinanny
uh but the most important issue here
truly emily
is the abuse of the term karen don't
take karen from us
because if you just throw karen around
in the wrong way we don't get to use it
and we don't get to enjoy it
and maybe that is the greatest
miscarriage of justice i appeal to you
[Laughter]
i rule affirmatively on that look i've
i'll just speak to
mayor lightfoot's tweet the whole watch
your mouth
or what why doesn't she watch her town
the statistics coming out of chicago
are undeniable nine children have been
shot to death
under the age of 18 since june 20th and
she talks about being left alone but the
pandemic has exacerbated all of the
stressors in those communities
that are experiencing the most violence
to begin with right
like unemployment spiking and infection
rates and
death rates so for her to focus on this
to throw around karen
to basically threaten kaylee and then
ignore her own town which is
rotting and festering again i think she
should watch her residence
she should watch her children and she
should probably listen to those
residents
who are saying enough is enough amen i i
feel
heard i feel your frustration and
hopefully
these leaders will tap into that and
they will at some point sprout a pair
and lead